Let's talk about the project you'll
be working on in this course.
You'll be using some common development,
packaging, deployment, and
monitoring tools to build a smooth
work flow for building and
launching changes to a web application.
Although you'll be working by yourself,
we'll talk about how you'll be able to
apply the ideas you learned here to
your own work place or future projects.
You'll start with fixing
a common problem,
difference between development and
production environment, by
creating golden images that can be used
by developers and on production alike.
Then you'll step into the shoes of a
developer and use the golden image from
the previous step to launch a local
development server for a web app.
After that you'll build out
a continuous integration service.
A system that will watch for
check-ins of new code and automatically
run tests and package it up.
Then you go back to the developer role
and see how pushing your changes to your
team repository automatically makes
changes to the integration environment.
And since you can't improve what you
can't measure, you'll configure a simple
monitoring system that will allow you
to see how your system is performing.
You'll also see how the perspective
of what important things to monitor,
depends on the role you're playing.
This, of course, is not the only way to
implement some of the DevOps principles
in an organization or a project.
But, it will give you
a practical overview and
let you walk in the shoes of
different people for awhile.
Will help you better understand some
of challenges other teams faced,
teach you how to communicate with them
better and how to work together to solve
the problems you're facing
in your everyday work.